secret window was directed by David
Koepp and stars Johnny Depp as Morton
rainy an author who is being accused of
plagiarism a guy who calls himself John
shooter shows up on his doorstep and
says hey you stole my story he leaves
him his manuscript and Morton combs
through it and realizes that it is very
similar to a book that he had written
and now we have a problem who wrote the
story first at the same time he's also
in the middle of a divorce with the
character played by Maria Bello and this
guy John shooter becomes more aggressive
every day to the point where Mort is
fearing for his own life and this movie
is based off of the novella secret
windows secret garden which was
published in four past midnight a
collection of Stephen King's stories and
with the dark tower and the new it
coming out we're going to be talking
about some Stephen King films
oh my contra something better than the
smell of a book it's like crack
look crack this is book crack I'm
telling you just have you ever done this
I'm serious let's just spend the rest of
this review talking about how great
books smell this came out in 2004 and I
remember going to the theater to see it
and I remember being very captivated by
it and a lot of it does have to do with
the fact that the story the idea of
these two clashing writers is highly
intriguing some might say that the film
goes in a direction that deflates that
aspect of the story and makes it a lot
less interesting and I can in a way to
agree with that this is certainly not a
flawless movie it has a lot of problems
that we're going to talk about but it's
held a special place in my heart for a
long time and that's because even though
I always like Stephen King movies it
took a while for me to actually read his
books and he's now my favorite author
and I have this movie to thank because
after I saw this movie it's a movie
about writers and it's very much so
about writing and the turmoil of going
through writer's block and what happens
when you come into a problem like this
where someone feels that you stole their
story there's some similarities and it
made me want to read the novella and I
thought well it's it's short I'll give
it a chance if I like it I'll read more
of King's work and ever since then I
have almost every single one of the
books and I've read a large majority of
them and so I have this movie to thank
for that
when this movie came out Pirates of the
Caribbean had just hit the previous year
and that was so successful they actually
released this one about a month sooner
than they had originally planned to help
cash in on that success the newfound
Jack Sparrow same and and you can kind
of still feel tastes of it in his role
here he does a lot of strange quirky
physical things with his hands like
after he washes his hands he's shaking
the water off as he walks around he'll
often wake up from his naps very
disheveled and pause and just look
around and he can really feel that Jack
Sparrow has still infected him ever so
slightly throughout the filming process
of this movie and it's his performance
and that character and the first act in
particular the set up for this movie
that really invests me Depp is great
here and I think it's one of his more
underrated performances but as the film
goes along it definitely loses steam the
second act gets really bogged down in
the fact that Mort is going through a
divorce there's a lot of scenes where
he's arguing with the new guy and then
he's arguing with her and it's just a
lot of domestic dispute stuff that it's
meant to give his character more depth
and it does you do care for the guy
because he was wronged and he was the
one who was cheated on but it goes on
and it goes on and you keep thinking
yourself I'm more invested in the stuff
with John Turturro and I would like to
get back to that story but knowing the
way the film ends and we're going to get
into spoilers here if you've never seen
a secret window if you haven't I do
suggest seeing it I think it's worth a
watch it's not a perfect film by any
means but I think it's a good film to
watch if you're interested in stories
about writers it was probably hard for
David Koepp the writer director to
figure out how to have so many scenes
with these characters without his twist
becoming known because you can't have
them do too many things in public
because then a lot of people would be
like looking and staring so they have
moments where characters do see them a
guy drives by and they make a big thing
of it to show this guy driving by like
okay there he goes and now we know that
he was seen so it's it's not in his head
when I saw it in O four when I was 16 I
didn't guess the twist it surprised me
but now as I watch it I can see that
probably I would have figured it out
before it ended if I had seen it for the
first time when I was
older and that's because there's far too
many hints as I said I didn't guess it
when I was 16 but I also don't go into
movies trying to guess the ending I
don't like to do that because part of me
feels like if I can figure it out then
the experience isn't going to be as fun
sometimes it's inevitable and you just
think of something and then you're like
oh that's probably what it is and
sometimes it is but in the case of this
movie I like how weird it is the movie
does kind of have a pair of balls
there's a lot of strange things that
happen in this movie very odd comedy and
moments that seem like they just
appeared out of thin air like this scene
for instance when Mort sees a dead body
and turns around and gets creeped out by
a squirrel in a tree when he wakes up
there's this elongated moment where his
leg has fallen asleep and he's tripping
over it also throughout the entire film
he will sometimes smoke but he hides it
from everyone and he refuses to admit to
people that he smokes people will offer
him a cigarette he's like I don't smoke
when he gets a chance he'll have a smoke
there's even a scene where he falls
asleep and has a nightmare that he's
falling into an ocean which
interestingly that's actually unused
b-roll from the lost world I've filmed
that David Koepp wrote and had a cameo
in he was one of the guys who got eaten
by the t-rex in San Diego so there's
just something weird about this movie
that I have always appreciated Mama's
little baby little short then shoot I
was a little bit in bread it goes from
thriller to domestic dispute to comedy
to back to thriller to domestic dispute
again the film doesn't always decide
what it wants to be
I think the first act is pretty damn
good and I really like the reveal and
the turn in Depp's character he's really
fantastic in the final moments of this
movie and it's very Stephen King Stephen
King is excellent at revenge stories
there's something that's amazing about
him that he can really pull off and it's
that he can take a story that on paper
is very disturbing or very sad and
somehow find the fun in it like he can
take a movie like Mystic River and
probably figure out a way to make it
drastically entertaining and very fun
and the revenge element of this movie
and how it all comes together in the end
is really satisfying
even though the twist does kind of
deflate the intrigue of the setup I like
all the performances and David Koepp did
a pretty good job crafting this movie he
has a lot of really cool shots in there
but sometimes his shots do come off as
hey look at this cool thing we did yeah
we figured this out in post he does a
lot of shots like that
the opening shot for instance at first
starts out as a lockdown camera before
deaf event early pulls away from the
frame and you realized that in one of
the wiper blade turns they probably did
a cut there so they could mask the two
shots together he does something similar
in the following scene where the camera
travels through the cabin into a window
then through a mirror and now we're in
the living room it's cool but sometimes
it does feel a little showing the score
for this film I've always really liked
it sounds almost 1980s but with a more
deep body of an orchestra behind it
[Music]
Oh
this film is worth checking out for the
beginning and the end the middle drags
for sure and it takes a while to get to
the cool stuff there's a lot of
relationship drama that gets really
bogged down in this movie Charles s
Dutton one of the best character actors
ever is pretty cool in this film and
he's also a bright spot of the movie
it's just that whenever Depp's character
leaves the cabin it's like the tension
just goes away when you're at the cabin
or in the woods you feel really enclosed
in the environment I watched it tonight
in 5.1 surround sound and you can hear
the forest and all the creatures
surrounding you and it felt so
penetrating but whenever he leaves the
cabin it's like okay let me just get
back to the stuff with the story because
that's what's cool I'm going to give
secret window of B it's certainly not
one of the best Stephen King adaptations
but some do refer to it as one of the
worst and I disagree with that I don't
think it's that bad I think it is worth
checking out guys thank you so much for
watching look forward to more Stephen
King reviews leading up to Dark Tower
and it you guys are the best thank you
once again if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you